The conflicts between Israel and
Palestine is one of them is complicated
in international politics and as you all
probably know,
it's one of the most controversial
political situations in the entire
world.
In order to make it easier in this
video,
we're going to tackle the very delicate
issue of the Israeli settlements in the
West Bank,
and this is a pretty major issue because
almost all countries find these
settlements to be a serious violation of
international law in the last 40 years.
All of the administrations in the United
States have taken a position against
them,
and when I say them,
I do mean all of them and yes,
this matter has compromised the special
relationship that exists between the US
and Israel.
And I'm not talking about governments
like Jimmy Carter's yet,
not at all.
Indeed,
Ronald Reagan himself demanded the
immediate freeze of any new settlements
as he claims they were an evident
obstacles piece.
George Hw Bush threatens to take
disciplinary measures of an economic
nature,
and then Bill Clinton proposed a law to
punish Israel by reducing American
assistance.
Even today at trump's administration has
asked Israel to stop being such a pain
in the ass about it.
Since taking office in January,
trump has publicly asked Netanyahu to
constrain suddenly construction,
but has not condemned.
The State Department has said that it is
not helpful to the peace process.
So what do you think Israel has done in
the face of all this criticism?
Well,
they have basically ignored it and have
kept expanding their settlements,
but okay,
now we are here.
You might be wondering what are these
settlements and what do they really
mean?
Well,
let's have a look at that.
Settlers and settlement.
Last thing we need to know is that
according to agreements that have been
reached,
the territory,
your state of Palestine is formed by
what is today known as the West Bank and
the Gaza Strip.
These territories corresponds to the
political map prior to the six day war,
after which Israel occupied these
territories which used to belong to
Jordan.
So the settlements,
they are essentially communities,
villages,
towns and cities that Israel has been
building since 1970.
In the West Bank territory.
You have the future Palestinian state
and it is not just a few houses we're
talking about here.
The West Bank is a small territory at
belly 5,600
square kilometers,
which is about the size of the state of
Delaware,
but even so,
and this is not considering east theresa
limp plant,
a 131 settlements and furthermore there
are an additional 97 out posts.
These are posts,
they are settlements as well if it in
these cases,
these settlements are illegal even under
Israeli law.
These are posts they were built without
the consent of the Israeli government.
That means that there are more than 228
Israeli settlements around the West
Bank.
Many are in places of relevant value
like aquifers and that makes it more
complicated because roads and
infrastructure need to be set up in
order to connect to them.
Besides Israel needs to protect these
settlements and that involves police
patrolling around the West Bank,
which affects the mobility of
Palestinians and makes economic
development even more difficult,
and the
problem isn't just the existence of
these is that they don't stop growing in
the last year,
more than 2000 new buildings have
started to be constructed and there are
plans to build $3,000
more in the next year alone.
Obviously in addition to this,
there are also medical centers,
schools,
synagogues,
etc.
So once the result of all of this,
well take a look at this chart to see
how the population has evolved.
So now you might be asking,
well,
what's the problem here?
Those who are pro settlements claim
these population centers are growing
where they used to be nothing.
Consider what the mayor of marley,
I remember sounds about one of the main
settlements.
We didn't steal the land from anybody.
It was built on empty hills.
You can see there the desert rocks and
sand.
Now you have a living city.
Then in cash rail mayor of ma'ale,
adumim,
ma'ale.
Adam is a city of 40,000
inhabitants with schools,
kindergartens,
a theater,
a library,
and industrial center according to the
residents that it's a complete city.
All right.
Again,
so what exactly is the problem?
the problem is that in order to solve
the Israel palestine conflict,
all parties agree the two states and
necessary one being Israel and to being
palestine,
but with all the sediments,
palestinian sovereignty in the west bank
will be in serious danger because Israel
has already said they will never give up
sovereignty over these places,
and that includes the roads,
the infrastructure,
the security controls.
Let's be clear,
palestine will be unable to become an
effective and autonomous state with such
limitations,
especially considering these
settlements.
Waves stopped growing.
Settlements are illegal under
international law.
At present,
one of the main impediments to peace
nicola and letting of united nations
envoy on middle east peace.
So now you can probably understand why
this topic makes everyone so 10 years
more and more
sure.
Ins and yahoo's settlement policy.
It hasn't stopped growing since 2015.
The situation has reached a point and
it's on the 23rd of December,
2016.
The un security council passed a
resolution 2134 that strongly condemns
the israeli settlement policy.
Security council reaffirms that the
establishment by Israel of settlements
in the palestinian territory occupied
since 1967,
including east jerusalem,
has no legal validity and constitutes a
flagrant violation under international
law and a major obstacle to the
achievement of a two state solution and
just lasting and comprehensive peace
resolution to three,
three slash four of the security council
resolution could be passed because for
the first time the us didn't use their
rights to veto the resolution as well.
This is something that made netanyahu's
governments really furious.
The prime miniSter didn't hesitate in
describing the situation is absurd.
Even accused barack obama's
administration in public.
I've tried to carry out a shameful anti
israeli maneuver,
so yeah,
he was pretty angry,
but this resolution shouldn't have taken
you by surprise given some of the
decisions he announced in 2016 and
confirmed in 2017
ready governments has started a new
settlements in the west bank,
which is the first for two decades,
so Israel not only has decided to
encourage the existing settlements,
but they've even started a new one on
the other hands,
maybe a powered by the alleged good
relations with trump.
The parliaments in Israel after lots of
controversy.
It finally passed a new law in the
beginning of 2017.
This lot legalized is around 4,000
houses built on palestinian private
property houses that the israeli supreme
court had even ordered to be dismantled.
Rules of the game have changed with
donald trump's arrival as president.
We no longer have our hands tied as we
did in the time of barack obama.
Now we could finally build and take
that.
As we said before,
the fact that trump might look closer to
Israel doesn't mean that his
administration isn't also tired.
Of this settlement issue,
that is why I'm in order to regain
trump's favorite jerusalem is committed
to starting a new policy that seems to
slow down the growth of existing
settlements and forbid outposts.
It's completely,
but the new policy,
it's so cryptic and complicated that it
seems very likely.
These settlements,
they'll just keep growing and now you
probably have another question which is
why do these settlements are they grow
so much?
Well,
pay close attention here,
inexplicably policy thinking about it.
Why do so many israelis want to live in
these conflict zones?
Is it because maybe there are some
valuable natural resources to be
exploited as well?
NoT really the explanation.
It's much less creative.
The government of Israel is subsidizing
the establishment of these settlements.
That's right.
The government in Israel,
[inaudible] finances,
the construction of houses,
creating discounts of almost 70 percent
for the price of land and offers a great
deal of financial aid and you know the
results as well.
Houses are 40 percent cheaper than in
the formal territory of Israel and say,
well,
that's not all the governments of
Israel.
Also interested is to get our take and
provides all kinds of public services,
so as you can imagine,
the youth ends.
Many families see these as places where
they can have a better life than they
could in israel's formal territory.
So now the question becomes,
well,
how does Israel itself benefit from
this?
Well,
the truth is they really don't.
So an exchange,
they get just a bunch of political and
economic problems.
These settlements aren't just an
obstacle for the peace process and
foreign policy because they are also a
big waste of public money.
So look with the subsidies,
the security,
the expensive public services for these
now foundation and the advert center.
Both israeli by the way,
estimate that the cost of these is more
than a billion dollars a year.
In other words,
this is nothing that's an expensive
policy both for the citizens of
palestine as well as those of Israel.
To get fooled,
let me be absolutely clear.
Israel is a country full of positive
things like that.
Neighboring countries.
Israel is a consolidated democracy with
strong civil liberties and a prosperous
and innovative economy.
Many of the products and services we use
everyday wouldn't exist if it weren't
for the technology developed in Israel
and don't be false.
Putting an end to these settlements
wouldn't mean and ends of the conflicts
because there is a precedence in 2005.
Israel left the gaza strip,
completely stopping all the settlements
and removing all civilians and soldiers
and the result was neither piece nor
prosperity.
The strip is now Controlled by hamas
radicals and it is even in conflict with
the government to palestine itself and
the situation isn't good from a
humanitarian perspective,
but it definitely doesn't justify the
settlement policy of Israel and their
lack of commitment towards the peace
agreements.
And so now the question is,
is there really any possible solution to
this conflict?
Well,
more and more experts claim the solution
needs to be a bottom up strategy.
That is to say encourage economic
development in the west bank.
Establish a dialogue and understanding
where trade relations between israelis
and palestinians and normal answer lets
the national authorities in palestine
have more jurisdiction.
These,
they will require time,
but more than that they require
commitments.
I said,
no,
it's your turn.
What do you think should happen with the
settlements?
Well,
please do leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this
survey,
and also don't forget to subscribe to
our channel for brand new videos just
like this every Monday and thursday,
and do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watchIng.